Наверняка у каждого человека в своей
жизни были случаи когда он о чём-то
жалел я уверен у каждого из вас такое
тоже происходило но сожаление о прошлом
- это часть нашей жизни хотя я везде
говорю что счастье убивает три вещи это
сожаление о прошлом Это неблагодарность
в настоящем это беспокойство о будущем
но в то же время когда я говорю про это
я говорю про постоянное сожаление если у
вас постоянное сожаление то это убивает
ваше счастье но периодические сожаление
случается с каждым из вас и со мной
происходило то же самое и вот глядя
назад если бы теоретически у меня была
возможность сейчас вернуться или
поговорить с собой двадцатилетним или
двадцатипятилетием что бы я
порекомендовал себе Давайте сегодня
поговорим об этом первое о чём бы я
конечно поговорил бы с собой двадцати
или двадцати пятилетним Я бы поговорил
бы о ценности внимания к сожалению в
молодости это не только со мной
происходит вообще происходит со всеми
молодыми людьми молодые люди не очень
ценят ценность своего внимания поэтому
они распыляют своё внимание то на
вечеринки то на социальные сети то на
различные виды активности то а на чтение
огромного количества литературы
просмотра видео аудио и так далее но это
наверное свойство вообще всех молодых
молодые люди брызжет энергии у них куча
энергии они занимаются всем подряд
бросаются на всё они пытаются найти своё
место в жизни Они пытаются найти тему на
которой можно сделать бизнес пытаются
понять где они могли бы а стать
профессионалом и где они могли бы стать
лучшим в своём деле поэтому как правило
у всех молодых людей а Существует одна
базовая проблема это огромное распыление
внимания на огромное количество
активности вообще а умение управлять
вниманием - это одно из фундаментальных
я бы сказал бы А способности или умение
человека Поэтому с молодости Я бы
обратил внимание на это к сожалению в
молодости я не знал силу внимания я не
знал что внимание обладает такой силой
что на что бы я не обратил внимания то
растёт вот я не знал вот эту железную
связку Что растёт всё на что я обращаю
внимание и вторая связка это то что
любая
проблема решается Когда вы обращаете на
неё внимание любая проблема - это по
сути сигнал
который посылается вам с требованием
вашего внимания проблема Вам
сигнализирует обрати на меня внимание
обрати на меня внимание обрати на меня
внимание если вы не будете обращать
внимание на проблему проблема будет
усугубляться она будет становиться
больше больше и больше пока вы не
придёте в ситуацию Когда вы уже не
сможете не обратить на неё внимание Так
что при первых признаках проблемы всегда
откладывайте всё в сторону всё внимание
обращайте на проблемы и держите на ней
внимание До тех пор пор пока проблему не
решить А если вы
хотите вырасти в чём-то Определите В чём
хотите расти и всё внимание направляйте
тотка туда и это будет расти и это
касается и взаимоотношений с другими
людьми и это касается любого вашего
занятия и совершенствование в какой-либо
сфере второе я о чём бы хотел поговорить
с собой молодым - это про ценность и
важность целенаправленного саморазвития
смотрите существует большое количество
людей которые вообще не не занимаются
саморазвитием это те люди которые я
считаю поставили крест на своей жизни
которые уже разочаровались поставили
крест или может быть даже не осознают
ценность и важность саморазвития но есть
Другая половина людей которые занимаются
саморазвитием И в основном это свойство
молодых людей постоянно в чём-то
развиваться что-то искать что-то изучать
и так далее но проблема здесь кроется не
в самом саморазвитии проблема здесь
кроется в том что у молодых людей не
целенаправленного саморазвития у меня у
самого такое было я развивался во всех
сферах во многих сферах я считал Так что
чем больше я буду знать тем лучше я
читал Очень много книг в захлёб в
результате я конечно стал эрудированным
человеком я мог достаточно хорошо решать
кроссворды Но в моей жизни Это помогало
не так сильно Поэтому вот знание
важности и ценности целенаправленного
саморазвития - Это очень важ крутое
знание Что такое целенаправленное
саморазвитие это когда Сначала вы
ставите цель а потом развиваете всё что
нужно для того чтобы добиться этой цели
то есть смотрите как молодые делают они
развиваются во все сферы Они думают что
само саморазвитие само по себе имеют
ценность так вот у меня есть лекция
видео Кстати на юбе она называется о
вреде лишних знаний это как раз я
говорил про Вот это про отсутствие
целенаправленного саморазвития поэтому
саморазвитие ценно если оно подчинено и
направлено вашим целям то есть учить и
изучать нужно только то что приближает
вас к вашим целям хотел бы здесь таже
также осветить ещё одну проблему есть
определённая категория людей которая так
ударяется в саморазвитие что не может
остановиться Ну вы сами наверное знаете
вокруг вас Наверняка есть такие люди
которые А в народе их называют ещё
вечные студенты они постоянно учатся
постоянно учатся им нужно постоянно
какие-то сертификаты мы подтверждения и
они всё не не могут приступить к
действию они всё не могут приступить к
действиям которые ведут их к их целям
они всё развиваются учатся ещё что-то
читают ещё что-то накручивают у себя и
так далее это такие я их называю ещё
патологические
коллекционеры различных компетенций а
компетенции - это товар на самом деле
скоропортящийся если компетенцию ту же
не применять то она сразу же устаревает
первая большая проблема когда люди не
проблема когда люди начинают
саморазвиваться и развиваются во всех
направлениях третья большая проблема
когда люди начинают саморазвиваться и не
могут остановиться так вот если бы я
например в молодости знал о ценности и
важности а целенаправленного
саморазвития или саморазвития
направленного на на только на достижение
целей Я бы сэкономил бы годы жизни и
кучу энергии и сил на то чтобы не
изучать ненужные мне вещи и кстати
обязательно те в комментариях про людей
вокруг себя которые находятся на разных
этих стадиях первое люди которые не
саморазвивающейся
развиваются и превратили себя в вечных
студентов и обязательно отметьте людей
которые целенаправленно развиваются то
есть они развиваются только в том объёме
и в том направлении которое необходимым
для достижения их целей и как правило
вот эта четвёртая категория людей
достигает жизни многого третье о чём бы
я хотел бы поговорить с собой молодым -
это умение строить отношения с людьми вы
знаете я много раз повторяю что Успех
любой Успех - это по сути не что иное
как продвижение по социальной лестнице
по социальной иерархии поэтому то каких
успехов или достижений вы достигнете в
этой жизни неважно это бизнес политика
культура искусство и так далее Всё
зависит от того как вас принимает или
воспринимают вас другие люди поэтому
умение выстраивать отношения с другими
людьми - это супер качество которое на
которое нужно обращать особое внимание Я
даже более скажу а такую вещь что я
заметил что в основном в основном Не
всегда конечно но в основном отличие
богатых и бедных в том что бедные не
ценят значение нетворкинга или значение
связей в то время как богатые очень
чётко понимают значение связей что самое
интересное потом когда богатые люди
достигают успеха Бедные люди как правило
в комментариях конечно пишут ой Ему
помогли связи конечно у него с такими
связями он а не мог не добиться успеха и
так далее Ну а что вам мешает с самого
начала с молодости заниматься
целенаправленно заниматься созданием
нужных связи поэтому третья вещь о
котором я поговорил бы с собой молодым -
это умение строить целенаправленные
связи то есть опять-таки строй связи
которые необходимы вам для достижения
ваших целей и плюс умение а выстраивать
отношения со всеми людьми вокруг с
вашими коллегами с вашими друзьями с
вашими партнёрами с семьёй и так далее
Это целая наука К сожалению которая не
учат нас в школе Удивительно мы люди
умудрились
запихнуть в школу столько предметов
которые не нужны нам прямо в нашей жизни
в то время как умение выстраивать
отношения с людьми умение решать
конфликты умение разговаривать с другими
людьми умение их убеждать умение
аргументированно выражать свою точку
зрения таких вещей в школе не преподают
поэтому умение строить отношения с
другими людьми мне к сожалению
приходилось это изучать на практике я
совершил в этом очень много ошибок и
третий лайфхак или совет который я
порекомендовал бы себе это более
внимательно отнестись к умению строить
Социальные отношения Я вообще рекомендую
в этом видео всем молодым людям
переходить к в мой Telegram канал где
ссылки я оставлю внизу где Я делюсь Вот
такими лайфхаками и своим опытом из
своей жизни и что бы я делал на их месте
Поэтому если интересно кликайте по
ссылки внизу и переходить четвёртая тема
о котором я о которой я хотел бы
поговорить с собой молодым - это
значение неудач и ошибок почему-то у нас
в обществе так сложилось что неудачи и
ошибки имеют негативный оттенок это
считается очень плохо смотрите с точки
зрения достижения целей и получения
каких-то благ неудачи и ошибки - это
конечно плохо но с точки зрения
саморазвития неудачи ошибки - Это самый
главный источник вашего саморазвития
вашего
самосовершенствования К сожалению со
школьных лет а нам и вообще всё наше
воспитание вбивает нам в голову что
неудачи и ошибки - Это плохо плохо быть
двоечником плохо там а не знать что-то
плохо совершать ошибку плохо когда у
тебя неудача и так далее на самом деле
вот эти все неудачи и ошибки являются
именно тем фундаментом которые вас
обучают Это я бы сказал лучшие учителя в
вашей жизни я бы поговорил с собой
молодым о том что не бойся неудачи и
ошибок Какие последствия от этого чем
больше вы боитесь неудачи и ошибок тем
больше парализует ваша деятельность
прямой путь к вашим успехам и ва
достижени это активная деятельность Ну и
конечно же не просто активная
деятельность но и активная деятельность
построенная на стратегии Кстати о
стратегии я делал выпуск обязательно
посмотрите выпуск про стратегию ошибки и
неудачи удерживают вас от активных
действий они как бы вас парализуют
Измените ваши отношение к ошибкам и
неудачам примите их как благо примите их
как своих учителей вообще в этой жизни Я
заметил так всё что нам больно
некомфортно то идёт нам на благо и Самое
интересное это касается не только вообще
ошибок и неудач это касается всего
Правда она как правило больна и
некомфортно но она даёт нам благо
или улучшает нас ошибки и неудачи тоже
самое И даже в пище Посмотрите всё что
невкусно то полезно то что вкусно то
либо вредно либо ведёт к полноте ещё
одно На чём бы я сделал акцент
разговаривая с собой молодым в отношении
неудачи ошибок Я бы предостерег себя от
совершения только двух типов ошибок
первые ошибки - это повторяющиеся ошибки
и к сожалению я в своей жизни тоже
сделал очень много повторяющихся ошибок
и второй тип ошибок - это ошибки с
необратимыми последствиями Вот всегда
будьте внимательны в этом отношении
особенно когда вы принимаете решение
всегда задавайте се себе вопрос Это
повторяющаяся ошибка Или это у этого
решения последствия обратимый или
необратимый поэтому то что касается
неудачи ошибок - Это благо за
исключением двух видов ошибок
повторяющихся и ошибки с необратимыми
последствиями и пятое о чём бы я хотел
бы поговорить с собой молодым - это как
можно ранее Осознание своей миссии
понимание того для чего я родился
понимание того для чего я живу понимание
своих желаний хотелок страхов мотивации
понимания того что у меня хорошо
получается А что плохо получается
смотрите любое эффективное движение в
этой жизни зависит от определения и
начальных условий это хоть и в
математике хоть и в физике если
начальные условия не определены то вы не
можете эффективно двигаться вперёд
поэтому для того чтобы эффективно
двигаться вперёд обязательно нужно
определить начальные условия вот возьмём
даже всем известную систему координатную
систему GPS это Global positioning
System у каждого из вас в автомобиле
есть навигационная карта так вот основа
навигационной карты - это система GPS
это система спутников которая выполняет
только одну функцию она определяет то
где вы находитесь Если вы не
определитесь то где вы находитесь то вы
никогда не придете туда куда хотите
поэтому для эффективного успешного
движения вперёд нужно определить чётко
для себя определить ваши начальные
условия А что такое ваши начальные
условия это определить то что вы хотите
чем вы хотите заниматься то что у вас
хорошо получается то что нужно людям что
они готовы будут платить и то на чём вы
можете зарабатывать деньги то что у вас
дравит то в чём вы постоянно
саморазвиваться за то чтобы заниматься
этим То есть когда вы определяете вот
эти занятия вы уже понимаете с чем стоит
заниматься А чем не стоит заниматься и
когда я говорю про миссию человека
многие сразу думают про религиозные
Аспект думают что это религиозная часть
Нет на самом деле Осознание вашей миссии
резко повышает вашу эффективность за
счёт того что вы просто отсекает то что
точно вам не нравится и то что не делает
вас счастливее а Осознание вашей миссии
- это движение от текущей ситуации к
тому что делает вам вас счастливее что
наполняет вас энергией и Что даёт вам
радость а это даёт как правило то чем вы
хотите заниматься и то что хорошо у вас
получается Поэтому чем раньше вы это
осознаете тем лучше к сожалению я
например
По молодости очень часто занимался не
теми делами которые мне приносят радость
или счастье или которые наполняет меня
энергией а я занимался всеми делами
которые приносят мне деньги я считаю что
это был неэффективный и неправильный
путь поэтому пятый пункт о чём бы я
поговорил с собой молодым это чётко
Определи свою миссию то для чего ты
пришёл в этот мир что ты хочешь изменить
Что ты любишь делать что у тебя хорошо
получается что нужно людям и только
после этого на чём из этих пунктов ты
можешь зарабатывать